My name is Tom Rago,
and I am the co-owner
of Rago Brothers Shoe & Leather Repair
with my brother, Tony Rago.
And today I am going to walk you through
a dog-chewed Louboutin shoe.
Approximate cost is $800 to $1,000.
When they came in to us,
the platform was halfway chewed off,
the top of the shoe wasn't there,
and the heels were all chewed,
all had bite marks on it.
And you would think that this
was an unrepairable shoe.
We are going to attempt to rebuild
the platform of the shoe,
the upper part, the black patent leather,
and get the structure back to the shoe.
[machine whirring]
To start out the process,
we are going to give this
to our repairman, Ronnie,
who is going to put this shoe together.
[heat gun blowing]
We are using the heat gun
to remove the platform
very carefully, trying to loosen the glue
between the shoe and the platform.
We now are putting the
platform down on the table
and taking a piece of bonded leather
and tracing out the platform
so that we can make a
mold for the other shoe.
[machine whirs]
What that involved is
flipping the platform over
so it looked like a left shoe
instead of the right shoe.
So we did that.
We took our measurements.
Once we've got that pattern,
we now are taking a hard piece of rubber
and we are shaping that with a Dremel
to match the other platform.
The platform, when you
get it from Louboutin,
it's a molded plastic base.
Molded plastic is not available to us,
so we cut it out of a very
rigid piece of rubber,
and we had to sand it to make
the exact curves that it needed to have
to fit the upper part of the shoe.
When you start with the
upper part of the shoe,
you take a flat piece of patent leather
and you take the inside material,
which is a bonded leather --
that gives it the structure.
That gives it the form.
[heat gun blows]
What we're doing now is we're
heating up the leather on the platform
so that we can stretch it,
make it more malleable
so that it has no creases in it.
And then we pull it and
attach it to the platform.
So, now we have the top shape of the shoe.
After we've gotten that,
we begin to form it to
the platform underneath.
[scissors snipping]
We have to mold that platform
around the top of the shoe,
and that requires us using a hand Dremel
to get the shape of the platform
to fit onto the upper part of the shoe.
That's just trial and error.
You may go through that several times.
So, now that we've repaired
the upper part of the shoe,
we're going to take the platform
and attach the platform
to the upper part of the shoe.
Now we are going to give the shoe
to our shoe repairman, Henry,
so that he can attach the
leather and rubber soles
to the bottom of the shoe.
[hammering]
Now what we're doing is
we're attaching the red sole
onto the bottom of the shoe.
We are going to take this shoe,
and we're going to edge
it with black paint,
so that from the side of the shoe
all you see is the black.
You won't see any red.
This shoe was really a challenge for us,
and we think it came out really great.
We think that when the owner
does get this shoe back,
her mouth is gonna drop.